belle et pour notre groupe le premier
enjeu c'est de voir au terme de cette
élection est ce que ce groupe
d'un point de vue numérique va pouvoir
conforter sa position et construit
contient aujourd'hui il comprend 43
sénateurs et je pense qu'on pourra
conforter cette position sur ces 43
sénateurs 20 sont dans département
renouvelables 14 son candidat et 6 ont
décidé de ne pas se représenter
principalement pour des questions de non
cumul de mandats donc l'enjeu numéro un
sera de voir quel sera le nombre de
sénateurs du groupe union centriste
après cette élection et puis le deuxième
enjeu ça sera comme nous l'avons fait
d'ailleurs en juillet avec le groupe
reconstitué complété de bien définir
quel sera notre ligne politique
notamment par rapport au présent
république et gouvernement alors
justement précisément comment on va se
positionner un ce groupe centriste du
sénat est-ce que vous allez soutenir la
majorité présidentielle ou bien au
contraire être dans l'opposition je
rappelle que vous personnellement vous
avez soutenu le président la république
oui moi j'ai soutenu très tôt le
président de la république dans sa
démarche à la fois par rapport à son
projet sa réforme et au son souhait
aussi de recomposer la vie politique
pour sortir d'un certain nombre de
clivages artificiels
donc je souhaite évidemment que notre
groupe comme il l'a fait d'ailleurs au
match juillet puisse afficher clairement
sa ligne une ligne pour de soutien
évidemment tout en gardant
l'indépendance du groupe
une ligne de soutien à la majorité
présidentielle ça sera d'ailleurs l'un
des enjeux de cette élection sénatoriale
de définir à l'intérieur du sénat
renouvelé quel est le périmètre de la
majorité présidentielle un groupe les
constructif est en train de se
constituer au sénat est-ce que vous au
sein du groupe centriste vous craignez
une hémorragie de certains non vers ce
groupe les constructif non je ne je ne
redoute pas ce risque je pense
d'ailleurs que qu'il n'existe pas nous
ne sommes pas dans une opposition
constructive
moi je souhaite que le groupe
s'inscrivent clairement dans un soutien
à la majorité présidentielle ça peut pas
dire évidemment qu'on est d'accord et
qu'on soutient absolument tous les
textes on est indépendants on est un
groupe
indépendant qui aura à faire son travail
législatif d'ailleurs comme tous les
parlementaires pour faire évoluer les
textes quand ils nous paraîtront à
pouvoir être amélioré